all right it's Thanksgiving week so
we've got something extra special for
you for the Thanksgiving spirit
I don't know how Thanksgiving connects
to chemtrails but back in September of
2014 I interviewed a guy named gain
Wigington who believes that chemtrails
are a climate geoengineering project the
interview didn't go particularly well as
you can imagine afterwards he actually
wrote a blog post of some kind accusing
me of doing some kind of hit piece and
being a shill for the establishment or
something like that anyway chemtrails
nothing gets me into the Thanksgiving
spirit like hearing about conspiracy
theories particularly involving the
alleged release of heavy metals into the
environment no further ado my interview
from 2014 with Dane Wigington it's a
pleasure to welcome Dane Wigington to
the program he is lead researcher for
geoengineering watch.org Dane pleasure
to have you on the topic today is
chemtrails for people who may not know
what these are let's just start there
what are chemtrails chemtrails is a
layman's term David for geoengineering
which is climate engineering also known
as solar radiation management so in this
case the size terms are very important
semantics are important so that people
find hard science data and not
conspiracy theory so this is an attempt
to modify the Earth's climate systems
there's a number of stated reasons for
this again one is solar radiation
management that would be a primary
reason stated by numerous patents we
have about 150 patents on these programs
and we have global governance documents
from Congress UN and so forth so this
the the primary stated purpose David is
to slow a runaway greenhouse effect by
filling the atmosphere with light
scattering reflective particulates and
in this case we're talking about heavy
metals the primary element is aluminum
so these programs are are quite damaging
to the human health organism and the
climate system as a whole so and how are
these how are these elements dispersed I
think that's a key question aircraft is
firstly yes this is this is intentional
payload disbursement for America
there may be some method of his first
meant by mixing additives in fuel but we
have patents film footage of spray
disbursements with material coming out
of nozzles on aircraft so this is an
intentional effort to saturate the
atmosphere with reflective light
scattering particulates for the purpose
of solar radiation management and again
speaking in layman's terms when we see
often for people to kind of link this
with what we see sometimes on the
Internet these are those images where we
sometimes see what seemed to be streams
of either air or liquid coming from the
back of an airplane is that what we're
talking about here is people have been
led to believe that anything you see in
the sky the compensation trail and quite
simply the science doesn't hold up in
this case people should be able to
distinguish for themselves when you see
a grid pattern one day of nothing the
next obviously there's something going
on and we know from the type of jet
engine of these aircraft David a
high-bypass turbofan jet engine which we
have a tutorial in geoengineering like
so dark so people can see on this engine
functions if for all practical purposes
it's incapable of putting out a
condensation trail except under the most
extreme circumstances so we have film
footage of this happening at altitude
people can view these videos at Gog and
watch.org or other sites so we know that
they're spraying from aircraft so let's
go through a couple pieces first just
you mentioned that we want to separate
this from conspiracy theories and I
think it's interesting to use that term
because some people do consider this a
conspiracy theory so first just to
provide some context for the audience
are there other so-called conspiracy
theories that you subscribe to in other
words do you believe that the u.s.
landed a man on the moon for example you
know I'm not researched in other areas
and I'm not gonna I don't want to go
into those areas because I'm not
research and I have no opinion I can
only say in this case we have film
footage of it happening so there's no
Theory involved we have about a hundred
lab tests in Northern California
hundreds from across the globe that show
that these metals are falling down on us
raining down those by dying gain I don't
want to interrupt but we're I want to
get to that but just to push back a
little bit on this in preparing for this
interview it seemed like on June 6th on
the US
say prepares radio show you did say that
you found it incredibly unlikely that we
landed anyone on the moon and that we
sent a buggy up there here's what I said
David I said this that I think it's
interesting that we could leap up there
in 1969 and nobody's been back that's
all I said and that's all I will say and
I do find that interesting I think it's
interesting that nobody's ever been back
but that's all I said okay good good no
I just want to make sure that all the
information I have is accurate and that
you did say you did address that on that
program and you're saying that you did
so let's get now I want to get into some
of the specifics though of the that's
perfectly fair yeah no we're not going
anywhere beyond that I want to talk
first there's just so much of this you
know and as a layman it's hard to wrap
your mind around everything related to
chemtrails I want to first talk a little
bit about the aluminum specifically
right the claims about aluminum I did
some research about this and I went into
it with with an open mind and what I
found was that there are some air
analyses that have been done for example
one from Phoenix which show levels of
aluminum and barium that are so high
that if the tests were accurate we would
all be dead that was kind of one set of
studies that I found and then the other
set of studies that I found showed that
while there were some levels of these
heavy metals in the air that they were
equal to or lower than what we would
consider kind of the normal levels that
that are not in any way a red flag and
don't suggest that any have been added
so how would you counter that data well
I can't speak for a tested Phoenix that
I didn't do but I can't speak to tests
in northern California some of which
were done by a u.s. Forest Service
biologist whom I work with and all of
these tests were done at the state
certified lab there's a massive amount
of aluminum barium strontium other
metals falling down in our rain now if
this was normal David it would not
affect aquatic insect life as it has in
Northern California in fact we've seen a
90 percent decline
90 of aquatic insect life in Northern
California 90 percent terrestrial insect
life decline we've seen aluminum
escalate in the rain tests from a
baseline that was already high of seven
parts per billion 2/3
450 parts per billion in single rain
event this is highly toxic rain there's
nothing normal about this and people
have been led to believe aluminum is
abundant so it's common to find in the
rain this is absolutely ludicrous
aluminum has always bonded to other
elements that should not be an Iranian
less you live in a Sahara dust storm and
quite simply it wasn't there before the
aquatic insect life would have already
been dead now Dana Dane as a scientist
if the and I asked this question not
rhetorically but because I want to learn
from you
if these numbers are indeed accurate
from northern California as you state
how is a scientist did you look beyond
the correlation of that data and
actually link beyond a reasonable doubt
the reduction of aquatic insect life to
so-called aluminum that has been
released by airplanes in the air how did
you link those two things to go beyond
simply correlation and to causation this
is what we've always called for David
when we know this metals falling on us
we know it wasn't there before we know
from California Air Resources Board it's
not coming from China as a lot of people
would like to assume and we know it's
extremely toxic levels so much so that
it's changing forest floor pH is 10 to
12 times toward alkaline we know this as
well because we tested I've been in the
field with USDA soil scientists and
we've verified this fact so bottom line
is there's a massive contamination it
matches the climate engineering patents
exactly my background back tile power is
with renewable energy we have so much of
whatever's coming out from behind these
aircraft obscuring our skies is blocking
70 80 percent of my solar update which
is the exact goal of geoengineering and
every single dot connects we're simply
saying that an investigation is
justified here we know we have a
contamination issue it's indisputable we
know we have massive UV radiation issues
now which is also a known consequence of
climate engineering so again we have an
awful lot of right but you're still not
telling so in other words we also know
that we have there's significant effects
to fracking and oil drilling we have
incredible amounts of plastic trash in
the Pacific Ocean right there are so
many other factors which you're not even
considering here you're simply saying
hey we see this
when we measure the atmosphere and we
see this happening to aquatic insect
life but you're not putting anything
together in terms of a causal
relationship you haven't stated anything
at least when you have patents that
state the express goal of spraying
aluminum from the back of aircraft when
we see this happening we have filmed
footage of it happening in fact when you
have the world's most recognized
geoengineers stating on the record that
their intent is to dump 20 million tons
of aluminum nano particulates into the
atmosphere annually right and you have
global governance documents from the UN
from Congress at what point we stay that
all these dots match up and certainly
this contamination is coming from
somewhere right again nein again I don't
want to belabor the issue but again I've
that's three times you think it's coming
from ask you where do you think this
contamination coming code because it's
new I'm not sure but that's the thing
I'm not a scientist this day now by
asking me that question you're going
down the same path that the religious
extremists go down when you hold on let
me get the question out it's not
familiar or not - let me get the
question out well I'd like to answer
that question we have film footage of it
happening so when you ask me about this
as if it's a theory when we have film of
kc-10s kc-135 c-17 Globemaster x' all
spraying at altitude with nozzles
visible i don't know where the
speculation is here ok so let me tell
our television and radio audience we're
gonna go to a break here but we're going
to continue talking to Dane the full
interview will be on our youtube channel
what I'm saying is something else though
Dane and and you interrupted me when I
was trying to get to it which is you're
not putting together a causal
relationship you're putting together a
correlation here and that's not that's
not good science but let's pause for a
second because I don't want to I don't
want to only focus on this because I
have so much else to talk about and
we'll provide all of your website
information people will have a chance to
do all the research so don't worry about
that I want to talk about when we see
planes that appear to be visually
spraying ok I focused a lot of my
research for this interview on this and
in fact I happen to live in New York
City we live I live in Brooklyn which is
basically at
the epicenter of three of major airports
LaGuardia JFK and Newark Airport so
let's go through my observations piece
by piece and then I'll let you tell me
where I'm kind of going wrong here the
grid patterns that have been identified
okay because of the take-off directions
that yesterday based on the way the wind
was was going that were being used at
these three airports you could see what
would be maybe casually in layman's
terms considered a airplane chemtrail
lines going from all three of these
airports and as I looked above there was
indeed a grid pattern because these
takeoff the take-off patterns
intersected and it didn't seem to me at
all like this was anything remotely
unusual I went back and found pictures
from a very early a VA ssin where we saw
the same grid pattern connect the grid
pattern to proof that this is heavy
metals being released into the
atmosphere first when you say very early
pictures we know these programs have
existed since the late 40s so we would
expect to see some pictures section over
Northern California we've pulled all FAA
flight paths we do not have east-west
flights above us but yet we have
east/west grid patterns on numerous days
we pulled through a congressional rep
the FAA GPS flight tracking records
showing these planes making loops lips
were loose you can't get these GPS
records without congressional approval
from state representatives so we know
that these planes are making completely
non conventional flight paths all over
the state we know this I mean we're not
guessing could it be attained and I
asked this couldn't it be that even
though they're not making what would be
considered a traditional commercial or
transfer transported of airplane flight
pattern that they could be doing other
things which in my research again this
is just my research going into this with
an open mind have all been identified
right sometimes these so-called
chemtrails are hold on a second hold on
a second hold on these like let me get
the questions now you know I don't
that this you're trying to be objective
here you're not when you refuse to use
the science terms I don't think that's
being them tell me the term I should use
and help phrase my question I'm an
engineer in stratospheric aerosol
geoengineering solar radiation
management stratospheric aerosol
injection there's what those those terms
imply proof of something that I haven't
seen proof of so let can we find a term
that would be more neutral we can use
for what are climate engineering no but
unfortunately let me use it let me pick
a term that I think is maybe more
neutral can I call them so-called
chemtrails would that be fair you can't
the mad you can't possibly believe I
would think that that's being objective
of course I don't this is this is
stratospheric aerosol geoengineering you
have a mountain of science to back it up
and if you use the terms you using you
come to conspiracy theory on Wikipedia
instead of heart science and it seems
that's the primary tool the journalists
used to try to discredit an issue that
has a mountain of Sciences but I don't
know about that I didn't use Wikipedia
at all from my research the point I'm
kind of going to is this in my research
Dan and again just let me get the
question out and I've provided you
certainly time to respond here it seems
to me that all of these visual phenomena
let me call them that that some in your
field call stratospheric zero at
geoengineering have been explained as a
combination of and I'll just state this
and then you'll have a chance to respond
fuel dumping smoke generators to study
wake vortices tankers that release fire
retardant for fighting fires or training
for fighting fires some engines release
exhaust some airplanes have flares and
then as you mentioned there is the the
may be albe it rare but existent
condensation so what proof do we have
and when I say proof I mean actual proof
that this is aluminum being deliberately
released for climate engineering
purposes what proof do we have first
David when you say that we should feel
better about something being a fuel dump
as if that would make things any better
I won't find that any better and that's
it we'd ever an argument when we have
film footage you don't dump fire
retardant at 30,000 feet okay when you
have
when you have military aircraft on film
sprang from nozzles and you have the
same material listed in those patents
showing up on the ground I challenge
anybody to look at the data when you
when you talk about your research I
don't think that it's really qualified
as research to say you've observed a few
trails and from the airports near you
we've done years of hard research we
have film footage of this happening we
have numerous lab tests we have science
documents we have in fact let's go back
to 1966 people can look this up global
now if they look of 1966 government
document geoengineering they'll find an
80 page presidential document that
outlines a scope and scale of these
programs as of 1966 10 federal agencies
involved 12 major universities involved
budgets in the hundreds of millions of
dollars that's hard proof David and
people need to investigate it again if
they look at the science they'll find
hard proof to back this up
a historical group of these programs
fair enough I will allow that to be the
last word on this we have gone over our
time what I would recommend to the
audience to do is the following
visit Danes website geoengineering watch
org look individually at each of the
claims that is made and then research
each claim individually because I think
that's the key to unpacking these
hypotheses which is step back from the
broader theory and look at each piece
that is said to make it up we've been
speaking with Dane Wigington lead
engineer geoengineering watch.org thanks
for being on thank you